what do you think is special about Eric
Weinstein for you know of his work and
his mind
the way he sort of straddles so many
different disciplines it's like a
renaissance man there are very few
people like that at any given moment let
alone the 21st century
where information has become so
you know huge that it's almost
physically impossible to be able to keep
track of things and yet
he does and he has his own unique vision
and unique point of view and he has
integrity
which is like almost impossible like I
can't think of
so many people who possess that those
qualities almost no one
and also the
ability
in some sense to um to embody the
balance that you talked about
of both the rigor of mathematics and the
uh the imagination Humanity also would
say you know like we talk about
imagination
um as a kind of a Counterpoint to
knowledge or logic
but just basic Humanity you know just be
basic just compassion just being able to
because
um
every destructive I would say like every
destructive
um
Society you know like be it Germany you
know and the Hitler or Soviet Union
under Stalin and so on
was based on some kind of uh what was
considered unassailable truth so a kind
of conceptual system you know if you
think about it right there is a
beautiful episode of this
um series by um Jacob bronowsky you know
um where he talks about he filmed it in
Auschwitz
talking about the certainty that what
led the Nazis to be killing people
wholesale
was a certain it was almost a
mathematical idea
and they just basically bought into this
idea and checked out their Humanity at
the door
so I would say that antidote to this
type of thing is not necessarily even
imagination in a kind of elevated sense
that we have been discussing today uh
that is exemplified by by our greatest
um scientists
and philosophers
but just basic Humanity you know basic
human basic common sense of just like
knowing that it's just not right and I
don't care what my see what my ideology
tells me but I'm just not going to do it
so
that I think is kind of missing a little
bit in today's society because people
get a lot too caught up in in the
ideology in in certain conceptual
Frameworks so societies that lose that
basic human compassion the basic
Humanity run into trouble
oh very much so but not only Society
like a human being and uh Eric is one of
the people I agree with you
keeps that flame of you like I trust
that he will not do something
that's not human that's not right
I just feel that you know like there's
some some people you just kind of feel
that they won't cross that line yeah and
that's a huge thing you know today
because I have to say looking back
definitely
I have not heard people personally but
like I could be mean for instance I
could be harsh
and now I see it as a sign of weakness
as a sign of insecurity
you know I saw I saw your interview with
Rick Roswell the other day
it's beautiful I was really moved by it
but you know that at some point I was
like
I I looked at him at this sort of like
Dr Evil
I'm kind of ashamed of it now but like
you know I'm kind of kind of clean
and I would you know
because well why because I needed an
adverse adversary in my mind because I
projected onto him kind of the fears
that I had that we will be the AI Will
Conquer us and so on
and this was rooted in my
kind of Awakening moment in a sense a
kind of a moment where I suddenly
started to see the other side
so but I wasn't sure yet
you see you have to feel it so I had to
have a fight about it yeah you had to
actually have the projection I had to
that so it was not in I I believe that
it was not in me already so I had to
throw it onto somebody yeah
and that's not balanced yet so balance
is when you recognize that it's you
actually so and I had this moment
actually and it was so amazing like I
would give this mean I would talk about
Ai and the dangers and he would always
be my like um foil you know I would put
a Sinister photograph of you on the
slide and it's like look at this guy he
wants to put Nanobots into your brain
and he's also like high-end High a top
executive at Google and so on like so I
would create this whole narrative
and then something happened
uh where I was giving a lecture this is
2015 at the in in Aspen Aspen ideas
Festival which is a wonderful Festival
so keynote speech actually and I and I
was doing my my usual stick and then
suddenly I said
I came up to that uh oh there was a big
screen and there was a picture of him
there and I came up to the screen and I
kind of touched it with my hand and I
said but
I don't want to pick on Mr Kosovo
because he's me I had this Revelation
that I'm actually fighting with myself
with my own fears
and and then I learned about
his
um his um his father that his father
died when he was young
and that he's in fact he's very
um discredited he's very um sincere an
upfront about it self-disclosure I think
it's very Essential by the way in all
this discussion like what really
motivates you
he said that he said it publicly many
times even as early as 2015 I could find
this information
that he wanted to reunite with his
father in the cloud and suddenly I saw
him not as a gray caricature
that exemplified all my fears but as a
human being
who a child longing for his father
grieving for his father
so suddenly it became a story a love
story
and you know
so that is so in other words I've seen
it in myself
this
capacity to
project my own fears and then fight with
other people over something that
actually was my own
and as soon as I got to this point of
seeing him and then my next lecture
actually I talked about it about him in
this way
and I and I said look you know it's a
love story and he is actually
um
and it's not how I would want to reunite
with my father
uh
but
like you said you know that if I am
consistent I have to allow the
possibility that different people
um
perceive things differently and so for
him
that's his imagination so you know how
who is this well Voltaire I think is
ascribed to Voltaire he's like I
disagree with you but I will fight to
death for you to have the right to say
yeah so now that I I feel like my
position is more like I disagree with
him that this is the way to
to approach death and to approach the
death of loved our loved ones and how we
miss them and how we
you know that sense of loneliness and
inability to interact directly
that
that's not something that is nice with
me
but I think it's also it can also be
called imagination from his perspective
and look motivated by that
how much he has brought
how many interesting inventions like his
in musical invest for instance naturally
because his father was a composer a
music composer and a conductor
so in other words from in the bigger
scheme of things
even if I think he is misguided
foreign
from his perspective to try to say that
this is the way we can all connect to
our loved ones and because it is sincere
and I see it now is sincere and in fact
in your interview you really teased it
out of human I was I was really moved by
it I have to say it's like he has mailed
a little bit too
you know it was really really sweet when
he talked about his father and I can
relate you know my father died four
years ago and I can relate with a
heartbreak I was much older than Rey was
when his father died but I can relate to
this um to this longing and that grief
you know and when he is somebody sincere
and he puts his
opens his cards and you know
and say this is why that's what I want
to do it because I want to recreate my
father and I want to be able to talk to
him this way
then we have a series then we understand
you know the opposite of it would be not
risk closing
and just
um
pretending that this is how it's
supposed to be in a scientific term so
really is replacing the real emotion but
come from the Heart by some kind of a
theory which comes from the mind and
this is where we can go astray because
then we get become captives of
Frameworks and conceptual systems which
may not be beneficial to our society in
tough times we need the people that have
not lost their way in the ideologies we
need the people who are still in touch
with their heart and you you mentioned
this with Eric it's certainly true I
disagree with them on a lot of stuff but
I feel like when the world is burning
down Eric is one of the people that's
you can still count on to have a heart
I've talked a lot over the past year
about the war in Ukraine and the
possibility of nuclear war
and it feels like he's one of the people
I would call First
um if uh if God forbid something like a
nuclear war will begin because you you
look for people with a heart no matter
their ideas that's right it takes
courage and it takes a certain
self-awareness I would say
and which brings me you know I think the
crucial is that that which was inscribed
you know on the Temple of Apollo
indelphia it was a statement No No
thyself know yourself you know the who
am I ultimately it goes down to this and
all these debates and the point is that
it's like I used to be like I said you
know pessimistic at some point and I was
scared even of where development of AI
was going this is about 2014 2015.
and now I'm much more so for instance
after I I saw Ray courtswell as a human
being after I could relate to him
and sympathize
with him suddenly
I I stopped seeing him in the news like
before that I would always see him in
the news saying we're going to put
Nanobots in your brain that by the year
2030 whatever you know and then we
upload you to the 20 by 21st and I would
be like no you know the story was
terrible suddenly I didn't see him
anymore
I had to you know so now it makes me
question who was creating the trouble
what was all with it was it him who's
creating stirring the trouble or was it
my mind you see and so as I become as I
became self-aware
suddenly other possibilities opened and
suddenly that conflict which by the way
if I kept giving this
nasty you know talks about him one one
day I suppose we'll have a debate and so
you have this
um one person says this and then yeah
and what I learned is that it never it's
a never-ending con this conflict just
does not end
but there is an alternative there is a
better way
which is to realize that it is you
arguing with yourself
now if you want to continue arguing with
yourself
continue as long as you need
just be careful not to destroy too many
things you know in the process but there
is an option of actually dropping it of
actually dropping it this is so I was so
surprised by this
yeah it's discovering in yourself the
capacity the human capacity for
compassion and you understand that
he has a perspective he is operating in
the space of imagination a human being
like you and we're all in this kind of
together
ultimately and also it's like with
realizing how much
I have screwed up you know Comes This
humility also yeah so like I find it
extremely hard now to like really Lush
out at somebody and to say like you're
horrible whatever because immediately
question is
who am I to criticize you know so is
there another way to have a dialogue is
there a way to you know speaking you
know since we talked about
um the innocence of a child and how much
it drives a discovery in science and so
on you know I remember I think it was I
think I heard the Ashanti who gave this
nice example he's like when you're a kid
you know you go and you you play with
your friends and then you fight with
another kid and he was like I hate you I
don't want to see you again I used to go
home like after half an hour okay what
are you gonna do you want to play so you
come out it's like hey you want to play
you don't talk about what happened you
don't rehash this you know
just keep going and sometimes I think we
are on the verge maybe of learning that
because I think that if we are can if we
continue to push
each of us our set of ideas and like
ideologies and like
you know what matters to us and so on
like yeah no no what matters to you but
like there are other ways to approach
other people there are other ways you
can find point of contact
speaking of which mathematics
mathematical formulas
are Universal represent Universal
knowledge two plus two is four whether
you vote for this guy or that guy in the
election you know how about that as a
point of of contact of commonality you
know and nobody can patent those
foremost did you know that there is a
Supreme Court decision that mathematical
formulas cannot be patented like
Einstein could not patent equal E equals
MC squared
it doesn't belong to him because if the
formula is correct
then it belongs to everyone